hey folks we're going to talk about
meditation for a second I get a lot of
questions about how to start meditating
keeping in mind that I had a very severe
allergy to the word and concept of
meditation for a very long time more
than a decade and I've only really
consistently started meditating and
implemented meditating for the last two
to three years there are few easy ways
to get started but before I talk about
that what is meditation
there are a few ways you can look at it
I think the simplest way to look at it
as a type-a personality is either as a
warm bath for your mind so that you
relax in such a way maybe it's only 10%
to reduce your anxiety so you can be
more effective and productive less
reactive in other words don't get
carried away by knee-jerk emotions and
judgments obsessing on the past
something that happened or something in
the future planning etc you're able to
actually a single task and focus that is
one of the outcomes one of the benefits
of different types of meditating all
right and that can take the form of
something very short or something a
little more involved I'll talk about
both the other and this is why I think
meditation can be viewed in a way as
stoic training or in some ways similar
to CBT cognitive behavioral therapy
because the objective is to help you to
observe your state and your thoughts so
that you are less controlled by them
what does this mean I'll use an analogy
that I think was originally shared with
me by Andy pretty comb who is he found
or something called headspace which I'll
talk about in a second which is the
difference in effect being say standing
out in the storm getting pelted with
rain and hail and wind and stinging your
eyes and so on being soaking wet or
standing inside looking through the
glass at the storm the latter is
meditation the way I've put it before
it's slightly different it's the
difference between being in the washing
machine or standing outside looking into
the washing machine and when you have
that somewhat detached observer
perspective you can just be much calmer
much more appreciative and ultimately
effective I do not think that meditation
causes you to lose your edge this was a
concern of mine and I get a concern of a
lot of type-a driven people but even if
it did cause you to lose saying 10% who
cares ultimately you're trying to
succeed and make more money do all these
things build a bigger business to
improve the quality of life for yourself
or others and you achieve that I think
more directly in many cases by even if
you had to take say a 10% haircut on
your edge by improving your present
state awareness by much much more 5207
so let's jump into a couple of options
right so if you're not dog because dogs
are always present then you need some
human tools one option and this is the
way I started very early on meditating
was listening to one song so find one
song that puts you into a good mood and
in the morning all you're going to do is
sit comfortably so this could be sitting
in a chair feet on the floor just like
this hands in your lap you generally are
going to want some type of back support
you do not need a dog chewing on a
squeaky toy so I may intervene Molecular
programs and three or you can sit like
this which is how I tend to sit when I
meditate so it's not full Lotus this is
half Lotus it's not even half Lotus
really just one foot tucked into the
crease of my calf and thigh and then I'm
going to kind of pull the butt cheeks so
they have a nice little seat here back
flat and then my hands are either going
to be in my lap like so or I will
actually post my hands on my thighs like
this which can also help if you have a
tendency of slouching to keep your back
straight
alright listen to one song for me it was
we're going to party like it's 1999
Prince it's hard to be stressed out
worrying about things if you listen to
that song trust me you can pick whatever
poison you like but this was shared with
me by Kamal Rob
and he suggested listen to one song
doing nothing in particular other than
listening to the song and breathing and
that's three to four minutes that's it
so you can try that in the morning that
was one of the first approaches I took
the second approach which i think is
very very effective and best for many
people is some form of guided meditation
this means that instead of sitting by
yourself and being completely dependent
on whatever's happening in your mind and
developing that skill of observation
you're listening to something and that
could be any number of different types
of audio so one would be and there are
many different types recorded guided
meditations by people like sam Harris
so Sam Harris org he is a neuroscience
PhD or Tara brach so Tara brach VR ACH
I've had on the podcasts and fair show
has a fantastic audio called the 2010
summer smile meditation you can find it
for free and some incredible folks like
Maria Popova for instance who runs brain
pick things to listen to that every
morning and credit it with really
changing their lives so those are two
you can find immediately just searching
right after this video you can also use
guided meditation that is more
progressive it's almost like weight
training there's progressive resistance
or progressive difficulty and there are
many good options out there so I've used
say headspace for weeks and weeks at a
time it is a very easy way to meditate
also if you're sitting in a plane or
sitting in a car and you can drop in
your earphones and you're good to go
another would be calm there are a number
of different varieties and options here
let's say that you've listened this far
and you're like I just I'm not some
hippy woowoo person I just want to
perform better really don't care about
this thing that you're calling
meditation okay well I have an option
for you because even in my own mind I
wonder when I see the benefits of
meditation which are generally better
sleep less dependence on caffeine you
become much more sensitive to things
like caffeine and alcohol better ability
to execute and focus on the important
things so maybe I'm not doing 100
I'm doing 20 with the 20 or better
thoughts are more important in fact I
[Music]
wonder though is the benefit coming from
simply sitting with really good posture
for 10 to 20 minutes is it coming from
the breathing is it coming from closing
my eyes and doing the breathing is it
coming from the exercise that I'm doing
inside my own head whatever that might
be or something else I happen to think a
lot of it is from the breathing all
right now if you then want to skip
meditation you could download an app
called apnea trainer which has pranayama
breathing and it is designed for free
divers I do not recommend doing any of
these breathing exercises before getting
in water you can cause yourself a lot of
trouble unless you have highly qualified
professional instruction ok but the
apnea trainer which was introduced to me
by Gabby Reece who's married to Laird
Hamilton so Gabby incredible world-class
athlete in her own right and then Laird
who is the last thing most people - the
undisputed king of big wave surfing at
least was for decades introduce me to
this and it will have you do different
types of breathing patterns and it will
count you down so it might say
five-second inhale five-second hold
ten-second exhale five-second hold that
would be one type that you could use
pranayama or you could do something like
five-second inhale 20-second holds
ten-second exhale and then back to
repeat that cycle and just listening to
the counting and breathing along with it
I find to be extremely calming and
centering I almost do all of my
meditation earlier in the day in the
morning I try to do it before turning on
the phone so if you look at my phone
right now well first is a coyote on it
but that's a longer story there is an
airplane icon up here in the corner
because I almost always have my phone on
airplane mode when I go to bed it's an
airplane mode and I try not to turn it
on because then you get the barrage of
bullets ie
text messages and different
notifications which immediately puts you
in your reactive mode so before that I
like to meditate feed my pooch etc and
then and only then maybe after some
journaling turn on the phone
all right other options for meditation
if you really want to get into it what
caused it to finally stick for me and
now I can play around all these
different options but what really got me
to meditate consistently was taking a
class and I took a transmittal
meditation class that's TM org these are
not cheap I think there's somewhere
between a thousand two thousand dollars
which is in my mind kind of silly but
Rick Rubin legendary music producer had
asked me if I had ever tried TM at one
point and then I took his advice but I
looked into it and I decided that I
don't have to pay a thousand bucks for
someone to give me a mantra at the house
of mantra anyway very skeptical but
continued to be very very stressed out
and then chase Jarvis is a very
well-known photographer and CEO of a
company called creative lives creative
live.com check it out it's fantastic I
said what do you have to lose you can
afford it so even if it ends up being a
complete waste of money now he was the
second person saying I do TM twice a day
why not just do it you can afford to
lose it even if it's a total waste of
time so I did and lo and behold having
someone to be accountable to who is
teaching me everyday generally during
lunch hour and in between sessions was
giving me the homework assignment of two
meditation sessions which I then had to
report back on and discuss with said
teacher it was enough social pressure to
get me to finally do it twice a day for
four or five days and at that point that
started an unbroken streak I want to say
of about a year and a half of meditating
at least once a day often twice a day so
that was really obviously one of the
tipping points for me if you want to get
the gist of TM and there's some weird
aspects of the organization that I'm not
a huge fan of but it's it's surprisingly
secular once you get past the first
meeting and the first meeting you have
to bring fruit and flowers and they make
an offering to the founder and it's a
little culty but once you get past that
then it's like okay what do you do if
you're in a hotel and room service comes
in and you're halfway through meditation
what do you do do you stop you talk to
them do you just ignore them or do the
coping mechanism so it's very tactical
practical in my experience
but they insist that you need someone
sort of as a life support indefinitely
to teach you TM the basics are you get a
mantra I think they're probably all two
syllables and if you want to get a
flavor for what that type of meditation
is like although I do think there's
incredible value in having a teacher who
holds you accountable you could take and
they would disagree with this but you
could take some two syllable word could
be nonsense or not you could use nature
right nature nature nature and save that
over and over and literally you're
effectively just repeating that ad
nauseam for the period of time in which
you're doing the meditation for
transmittal meditation they generally
recommend 20 minutes first thing in the
morning and then 20 minutes let's say as
chase does it right before dinner
crying I almost always just do the
morning meditation back in the day I was
more diligent about doing it twice a day
I do think there's a lot of value there
but if you just get it in the morning
there is a lot of value to be had and
beyond that I would say if you want to
start super small you could just do an
experiment and the experiment is not
twenty minutes in the morning not thirty
minutes twice a day it's not a long
guided meditation nothing like that and
by the way the apps I mentioned are
generally modifiable in terms of
duration so you do 10 minutes 15 I did I
did 10 for weeks at a time when I was on
book deadline for instance but let's
make it even shorter what you could try
they're two different types so one is
something that I start doing for myself
whenever I would get anxious or I felt
myself maybe getting angry or a
groundswell of emotion that I felt was
unpleasant or unproductive I would take
what I call the three breath break so
three breath break is exactly what it
sounds like you stop what you're doing
that's one just do that three times and
it's amazing how well that diffuses what
could otherwise become really stupid or
rash decisions and pretty easy so try to
remember to do a three breath break and
you can do that for a day or two and
very important set that intention in the
morning so set that as a clear objective
for the day and then at night review how
often you used it when you could have
used it when you didn't
this type of pre and post game is very
important if you're going to do an
experiment with something very small
like that and then I would say the next
you could test and this was in my latest
book tools of titans but the basic gist
this is I believe it's loving-kindness
meditation but forget about the label
because it sounds - woowoo and it's
weird sounding but Meg so chade-meng ton
who was previously at Google's one of
the very early engineers he developed a
course at Google available to employee
is called I think with search inside
yourself and it quickly became the most
popular course within Google thousands
of employees there's a wait list for
ethics six months and taught many
different tools related to mindfulness
and meditation and one of them which and
he tells a story that is in tools of
Titan's about a woman who tried it had
never done meditation before and she
said I had my best day in seven years
okay well what provoked that a very
simple approach and I've heard said a
number of people have said before that I
think Andy I mentioned him before has
also said ten minutes of meditating on
other people or the wider world is worth
ten hours of meditating on yourself all
right so let's assume that's true one
very easy way to test that out is when
you're doing say your three breaths
break or you just take a few minutes
five minutes to sit down and in the
morning for instance or whenever you're
feeling stressed out think about a few
people you're grateful for and then wish
to them to be happy that's it
so you just imagine three people you're
really grateful for they could be new
relationships old relationships maybe
childhood friends you haven't seen in a
really long time teachers from long ago
think about them and then you're just
going to
wish them happiness and hope that they
are happy and hold that in your mind for
a few minutes it sounds so silly and so
simple yet that is what this woman did
where she was in her office and I think
every hour she thought of a co-worker
and wished them a penis and she did that
for a few hours and I had the best day
in the office as I've had in seven years
so you can tried that also very very
simple so if you're like I don't think
about my breath or by this my that track
my thoughts I'm too scatterbrained Bella
okay fine just think about a handful of
other people two or three and wish them
happiness it's so simple I did this when
I was finishing tools of titans or I was
about two-thirds of the way through I
was overseas and I did a sauna every
night because a bunch of my guests do
saunas every night so I started doing it
and I would sit there and sometimes we
doing editing by hand I get too sweaty
get to where I couldn't do that I would
sit there and I do this loving-kindness
meditation and I remember getting to the
end of the week and thinking to myself
and asking why am I so happy I mean you
kind of know you need to fix things if
you ask yourself that but I tend to be
pretty tightly wound very aggressive and
focused a lot more on achievement than
sake intended are having this in most of
my life but man that week was amazing
and there were other elements as well
but the main variable that I tweaked was
this tiny tiny exercise and so in
meditation as in everything else I think
it pays to look for the very little
tweaks that have very big payoffs so
hopefully that helps those are a few of
the things that helped me to develop a
mindfulness meditation habit edie last
but not least if you meditate for a
period of time then you fall off the
train don't beat yourself up just get
back on the train doesn't do you any
good to self flagellate because you
missed one or two meditation sessions
this isn't the Olympics of meditating so
just get back on and then you'll see the
results and you then have the recipe
that you can use anytime you want thanks
for watching guys I hope you enjoyed it
and if you want to see more I have some
fantastic stuff coming including
collaborations just click here
first to see it